Yes, so we will.
Start with the the SDLs.
Aspect, but before that,
since you have the mid sem on the
upcoming week,
I want to take up questions.
Are there any questions you want me to
add?
If you have any questions,
you can let me know.
Just to reconfirm,
contact center session one to seven are
in syllabus, right?
Today's session is not part of mid-sell.
Yes.
Right, so basically model one and two.
So.
Okay.
So,
the SESHA has asked that we should focus
on to be confident that, I mean,
the syllabus itself is very less. OK,
so we have had only two aspects.
So what we are actually discussing in
those two aspects is in the first module,
we discussed on what is actually changing.
What are the changes and how many of
those changes are effective?
What are the changes which are not yet
accepted?
Right, for example, deployment monitoring,
it's not accepted that well.
Requirements elicitation,
today we are going to talk about it,
it's still not accepted as much as coding.
So coding part,
the build part is where we are having a
good amount of acceptance because of the
tools and technologies we have.
So,
but when we are having it in only one
part and it is not spent across all the
parts,
there are many risks which are involved.
We are not able to work at the amplified
velocity of the code because review is
still manual. So the risks involved,
what it causes.
the problems, the truths it causes,
the depth it causes.
That's what we had discussed.
in module one and something on cost.
So what are the additional cost it brings
in? It not only brings in...
So when we have.
tokens and when we have to,
there's always a running cost.
When you have a normal software,
it is the infrastructure cost and once
you load it and put it, it is still,
you don't have much of day-to-day running
cost.
But when it comes to API calls to AI
models,
Continuously.
Then there is a cost which is involved
throughout the software.
And we have to look at the tokenization.
We are all running with limited resources.
So we have to understand how to utilize
cost better, etc.
So these are the changes.
So first module is about
what exactly the drift, the change,
what is changing.
So that's what we have discussed, I think,
over a period of four classes, et cetera.
Then we had the second module to
understand what exactly is this AI.
Everyone is talking ChatGPT,
everyone is talking Gemini,
everyone is saying Copilot,
but what exactly are they?
what is running in the background.
Without getting into too much technical
architecture,
we understood the evolution of AI,
where it started,
what are the different algorithms which
are happening.
learning, unsupervised learning.
The large language models,
how do they understand the text?
How a text is getting converted into
tokens?
What are the different types of
tokenization methods which are available?
And what was the problem with large
language models? Where did they stop?
And where did the reasoning part come in,
large reasoning models,
and different types of...
Models,
different types of agents we can build
from the.
language or RAJ reasoning models.
So what each agent are capable of doing.
So that is what we discuss.
The basic foundations which is required
to actually help you to do or augment
these AI throughout the SDLC phase.
So that is what we discuss.
had looked at.
We didn't get into the technical aspects
because you, I mean,
that is not this course is intended for,
but we cannot also ignore the
tokenization part or ignore what is a
large reasoning model and get into a AI
Augmented SDLC course.
So the bare minimum which is required,
of course, all of you have to go and.
If you are going to use it in your
day-to-day work or in your projects,
you have to go in-depth knowledge that
whatever we discussed will not be
sufficient for elsewhere.
But for as far as this course is
concerned, that should be sufficient.
I mean, I'm just giving you the.
Understand.
So now we know what AI is that Black Box
is capable of and how it is actually
working.
And we also know what is the change. So.
What we have to do,
it is not just switching on or clicking a
button.
There are many things we have to do.
Though AI is Augmented,
we are not able to just live with just
prompting the AI and leaving it.
We have to do a lot of engineering around
it.
And that is where we discuss the
importance of.
prompt engineering,
which led to context engineering,
and then it led to harness engineering.
And then we have the graph and the loop
engineering, which I'm leaving it still,
it's still in the open phase.
Maybe we will, once we get it into two,
three weeks later,
we might have a good amount of.
information on the loop and the graph
path.
So till harness is what we discussed in
detail, because we have to do all this,
a lot of engineering around the AI output
or AI data which is coming to us.
So that is what pretty much we discussed
till the last session.
So all these are important.
I cannot say that this is important or
that is important. The concept itself is
less.
So you have to just have a good
understanding. As I said,
there will not be any questions apart
from what is covered in the contact
session 7 sessions.
Plus there will not be any remembering
kind of questions or recall kind of
questions.
It will all be applied questions,
scenario based questions where you have
to apply.
these thoughts,
you'll be put into a situation and you
have to understand what would be,
or you have to justify what works well
then, or what would be the answer.
Right, so that is what you have to do, so,
so let's try how it works. We,
I will always get your feedback after the
mix and we will can connect.
and see if there are any changes,
what difficulty you all faced,
because all of you are writing for the
first time.
Let's see how it goes and we will post
correct it in the future. Okay?
And you don't have to,
this is not always WILP or bits as such,
we don't rely on one examination.
Our evaluations are continuously spread
down,
so you have multiple options to improve
yourself.
So this is not the ultimate and exams are
not the only thing.
So you can be relaxed at this time.
A few things from my side.
So you will have,
so there is a question from KAUSTUBH.
How many questions?
Yeah,
so roughly you will have five to six
questions depending on which exam you are
taking up, etc.
And there are different sets for
different locations,
but all of them are in similar lines.
So you'll have roughly 5 to 6 questions.
So each question.
That will be.
A concept which you have to explain,
and say there is a five mark question, OK?
And there are two subdivisions;
a scenario is given,
and there are two subdivisions.
It will be equally between the two
subdivisions;
the mark will be equally divided,
so you can look at the scenario.
what the subdivision question is trying.
So if I give you one scenario,
there are so many questions I can ask out
of it,
but you don't have to write everything.
What are the two subdivision questions
which are asking or which they have asked
in that particular question?
You can write only about that.
You can be very crisp.
You don't have to write pages and pages.
You can be at least in answering the
points,
and we can we are not going to evaluate
based on the number of lines or number of
words, etc. So,
you can be very short and concise in the
way you are.
answer. Okay,
there will not be any one mark question.
There will not be any MCQ questions.
There will not be any choice in your
question page.
OK, this is common things which we follow.
So to answer Joseph Tom's question,
we don't have a previous year question
paper because this course is offered for
the first time,
but I have given a sample question,
two questions I have given to give you an
understanding of how questions will occur.
So you can refer to that as a reference.
Yeah. Are there any other questions?
I think we are done right.
Okay.
So today we are going to talk about the
traditional SDLC transitioning into the
AI native SDLC.
We have discussed in this sort,
but we are going to be more specific on
the steps which are actually happening,
etc. So code,
all of us know that code is no longer the
bottleneck.
Organizations have started using AI to
write the code,
and they are doing it at an unthinkable
speed, but yet.
The shipment or the process around it is
not changing because we have a lot of
things to do around it.
So what actually has happened today is
only this layer,
which has been the implementation layer,
we are good.
But still,
here we are experimenting manually.
This requirements solicitation and
designing the architecture requires a lot
of human inputs. Of course,
deployment and monitoring.
All the places we are augmenting AI,
but there are it is not happening as
smoothly as the code faces, right? So,
the Software Development Cycle,
which takes the idea.
I mean,
which takes the software from idea to
production.
Most organizations go through these six
phases, right? Planning, design, building,
testing, deploying, and maintaining.
Each is a discrete phase.
So it starts with the requirement
collection,
technical architects then turn them into
design,
then we have the software engineers and
developers.
what's coming and building in,
then we have the QA team, then we ship it,
and then the operations are there,
what is running.
So this is roughly irrespective of the
process model. We do it in circle,
Seven.
we do it in increment.
This is how it works, right?
BJP is actually changing about the
changes in Pakistan.
The.
I would request all you to be on mute.
Bing, which amount accepted?
So now if you take this traditional
software cycle, it is process heavy.
Why this process heavy?
Because we are working with large complex
softwares and we have to ensure
accountability and control at each step.
Right? So that is why it is process heavy.
Plus the traditional SDLC was designed to
maximum efficiency.
In the era where, if you look at all that,
the most time consuming and expensive
stage was writing and implementing the
code.
That was the phase in which it was more
extensive before even the incremental.
I mean,
they are talking about the era when I say
building and shipping was the, sorry,
not shipping,
building was the time consuming one.
They are talking about the increment
before the incremental.
deployments, the continuous CICD pipeline,
right?
We have to wait for the until the entire
software is being constructed before it
is released and then features come in.
But now we have,
we start with an MVP and then we work on
different PRs which can improve feature
wise, etc. But still the.
time-consuming part and even if you take
a small feature in your PRD,
the time-consuming part would be the
implementation aspects.
Right, so the traditional SDLC,
every step is performed by humans.
And then it is handed off to the next one.
Right now,
the code is no longer the bottleneck,
and the build phase can shrink.
Right.
We have three different things,
or we have a few things which has come up.
One is the more bottleneck is now moved
to the review or the other phases around
the AI because, sorry,
around the build and not the build.
So now we have,
we have how we are going to align human
power.
We are going to align resources,
et cetera, is going to change.
around up,
it's not going to be in the build,
it's going to be around the build.
Like the bottleneck has moved,
so obviously our planning where we should
invest resources also should change.
Right? So build is happening at AI speed,
but still review, testing, deployment,
planning is happening at human speed at
this point today. Tomorrow,
I think it will improve,
but I am talking about the reality what
we are there today.
The controls stop matching reality.
Reviewing each line. Okay,
so just because AI is able to generate
code at a faster pace,
I cannot put hundreds of testers and test
it immediately.
Reviewing each line of code generated by
AI.
manually doesn't make much sense.
Reviewing each line.
Made sense only when a human actually
wrote it, right?
But it cannot keep up with the face of
the agents.
So that is the shift we have to
understand.
It's not just we know that build is
happening shrinking the timeline.
When I say shrinking the timeline,
so what will happen? Test in this diagram,
they have just given test as equal to the,
so this size of the test,
and this is same.
But practically this will not happen if a
human is going to review this.
Or if you are going to follow the
existing testing practice,
test will run from here to here.
Right,
which is no point in actually reducing
the build cycle, etc.
So that is something we have to address.
Governance cost increases because
exceptions.
still route through those meetings, etc.
So governing that system,
validating that system,
actually increases.
So build is no longer the constraint that
we are clear.
The human speed steps around it.
are where we are having problems. So now
This is where the bottleneck.
It's not the build anymore, right? So now.
..
I have been talking as talking about
bottleneck, right?
But what exactly is the bottleneck?
Can anyone say?
I'm just saying test is the bottleneck,
et cetera.
But can anyone say with an example?
What could be the bottleneck?
Or, what is the trade-off here?
Okay, let me put, yeah,
review is that trade-off.
Yeah, not working efficiently, so that.
Say there is a security regulation
organization team.
Security teams are sized for human output,
but when agents come and multiply the
code.
Either the review queue builds,
it expands,
or the code has to be shipped under
review without being reviewed or reviewed
at a very smaller.
Aspects only.
Right,
so there are two things: either the
review queue bills takes more time,
or the core shifts under review. So,
in both cases,
a regularized or regulated organization
cannot accept either of these outcome,
so they have to the security checks or
the reviews happening have to keep in
faith.
agent, right?
So that is where we are going to the AI
native SDLC. Okay, the name,
I'm not convinced.
You can call it AI Augmented SDLC.
You can talk up, you can say it is,
or in simple words,
we can say that AI used in every phase of
SDLC.
But this is what is the name generally
everyone is using, so I am also using,
but there are a few oppositions to this
name also.
Is Sundar Ram say something?
We have also seen that LLMs add extra
code, which is not required. Yeah,
I'm going to talk about that technical
depth, right?
We discussed about technical depth
earlier also, so what is happening?
How do we?
So, AI is not working as expected,
so we have to use it in a way that which
will fit our needs.
Okay, so for a software engineer,
it is also necessary that we don't write
many lines of code or we write only what
is necessary because we have the job of
maintaining it also, right?
It is not that you give me 5 lines of
code and I will take the first two,
whatever is sufficient for me.
It doesn't work like that.
Right.
Yes,
so GURURAJ says in hospital treatment
holds until registration.
So here the problem.
So, GURURAJ,
the example or the metaphor you are
giving here is apt for the...
requirement solicitation because until a
man,
I cannot say a human to just verify all
the PRD in a speed of two minutes or
three minutes in where the AI agent can
generate the code, right? So.
Because the review is not happening,
it will not even go to the builder stage
at all.
Okay,
and it will finish the build stage in a
span of minutes,
and now we will be waiting for review.
So that is where the bottleneck is today.
Right, so...
To better get.
the productivity gains out of AI and
security is also not an afterthought.
All this,
the traditional SDLC cycle has to go a
change or transformation.
Completely,
not only in the build or the
implementation phase.
Okay,
so that is what we call it as AI native
SDLC or AI Augmented SDLC.
I'm just giving you different names
because you will be going and reading out
articles,
you will be interacting with your team.
So they might be saying the same thing
under a different name.
So that is why I'm saying you should be
open to changes.
So AI native SDLC is a reimagined process.
that combines the old control objectives
with new enforcement.
So,
AI is embedded at each point of the SDLC,
and it promotes an automated handover.
and triggering of the next phase,
helping to address.
the manual and the clunky nature of
handoffs between the phases of
traditional stSemAIMLstudentsdocs.
Okay, so as I mentioned,
the names will differ.
Some will call it as agentic SDLC,
some will call it as AI is DLC,
some will call it as agentic Software
Development,
some will call it as AI native,
AI Augmented. So the name will differ,
but this is the idea.
Right.
So if you look at what is happening in
the traditional cycle, we plan,
we require that we gather requirements
from a committee and through a set of
workshops and sign offs written by humans.
When I say written, it is not handwritten.
It is just documents.
We hand it over to the.
Next design phase, right?
And then spec will be written by the
analyst, the PRD,
detailed technical documents, I would say.
When I say spec, again,
there is a lot of different way spec,
the word spec is used. Okay,
so I would refer to...
the product requirements document which
comes from the planning stage as the PRD,
the technical specification which comes
out of the design phase written by
designers, architects, analysts, etc.
Then comes the coding phase.
Then we write code and some basic things.
Test which are edited and documentation
also is done after the development has
happened,
or if they are following a contract first
approach, etc.,
they might do the document first as well,
then comes the testing phase where QA
write test cases.
They test it.
And they also produce reports.
And humans review basically all aspects
of code. And then in a deployment,
you write deployment aspects.
You will either write infrastructure as a
code or you write,
you configure your infrastructure,
the CICV pipeline, etc.
And there is a monitoring phase we
monitor through various other tools we
have in the maintain phase.
And we also have a lot of automation
there meantime to recover the
the Netflix Chaos Monkey.
Have you heard of the Chaos?
Monkey from Netflix, anyone?
Yes, says yes.
So what Netflix did is they had multiple
microservices.
The numbers have increased to thousands,
I think.
They have a monitoring system, uh,
observability one, which, but the time.
it takes to recover from a failure,
you cannot expect a human to go and do
the recovering. Right?
So what Netflix did is it built a
resilient tool that can
capture the capability of the system,
how it can withstand unexpected failures
and recover from it.
So there was a tool which was developed.
It's called as the Chaos Monkey,
and it goes and randomly terminates
virtual missions in real production
environment.
and services in production to test how
well the system can withstand,
to understand how it can self-heal itself
and come back.
Right, so...
That was a very interesting thing because
you are not,
there also we have attempted to reduce
the dependency on humans to recover from
failures. It was an automated thing,
but it was even before the AI era.
It's an open source tool developed by
Netflix,
which comes under the chaos engineering
principles.
Many of the companies have adopted it.
They, I think Netflix and Uber.
or to extend PayPal.
All these were pioneers in microservices.
They did a lot of things even before the
AI came in,
which had made the entire software
development so efficient in terms of
adopting to CICD, et cetera. Right.
So that, I mean, a little just off to it.
So we have been doing this without AI.
Now when AI comes in,
what will happen is it will,
in the plant stage,
it will synthesize the pain points,
it will augment you to generate.
the PRD, it will capture all its intent.
So it is like an agent is sitting along
with a group of product managers,
and then it will come up with a document
which is both human readable and mission
actionable. And then in the design phase,
it will also start designing.
So if you give a PRB document to an agent,
it will start writing the architecture.
It will go into the, I mean,
at this point,
many directly go and start implementing
it,
but you can also force it to come up with
an architecture specification.
Guided by standards,
versioned in any versioning system,
and then the build phase that is very
common now, so it can be generated,
the code can be generated,
and it will also...
Based on the PRD,
it can also generate a valves test,
which can test the implementation.
And then governance is also can be
enforced at AI with the approval gates,
guard rails, etc.
And agents can also monitor live
deployments and it can work like a chaos
monkey.
It can also work like to recover that,
etc.
So this is what we are going to do,
but how to do it, right?
That is where is the question we have to
address today.
Now, before.
The development phase or the SAI phase.
We had the term white coding, I think,
two or three years back,
I think it so white coding.
This has an option to give some prompt,
and instead of rewriting the code,
the AI agent is writing a code for us,
right?
But when we looked at it, while coding is,
it looked good,
but it was not sufficient for real
products. Okay, for a for a POC,
I want to do or just I want to try
something or learn something,
while coding work by.
You can just give the natural language
information you have,
and then you can get the code.
Development can collaborate with AI
agents and they can get it done,
but that alone was not sufficient, right?
So,
spec driven development is an approach.
To the AI native software engineering.
The AI native SDLC cycle.
Through which we can go beyond by coding
and use the power of AI agents to to the
real software development life cycle,
or I would say spec driven development
elevates.
the software engineering to a higher
level of abstraction with structured
approach.
I mean,
in different from what white coding was.
So there are many tools which do this
spec driven development. We have three.
Three is what I'm going to discuss today.
The Kiro, the spec kit from GitHub,
and the agentic SDLC, sorry,
AI native SDLC by Anthropic.
Right, so as I mentioned,
AI native Development,
the real challenge is to keep all the
phases except implementation phase
aligned with the speed of the.
build phase. Also, the requirements,
design, implementation, validation,
aligned so the final result is still what
the original intent was.
It should not be a deviated one from what
the original intent was.
While we are developing at speed,
We should run towards the pole which
gives us the victory.
Just because we are running at speed,
we cannot run in a different direction.
and we end up in a poll which is
different from what the original intent
was, right?
So that is where we have to also be
conscious.
So spec driven Development gives us that
structured approach where the spec will
be the shared source of truth.
For both the humans and the AI,
and instead of prompting, we will rely on.
a clear specification throughout the
entire phase.
So why do you think AI assisted
Development still breaks down?
Leave the I told you the bottlenecks, OK?
Rev manual have review.
Manual review happening.
All that, right? Still, AI,
so even if you are able to review it,
during review,
you find that AI development is not up to
the mark, right?
There is some place it breaks down.
The translation is not as smooth, right?
It is like an intern.
You hire an intern to do a some feature
for you.
You try to explain the task to the intern
and ask it,
ask him or to do it and come back.
you find there are problems or maybe the
understanding the intern has is not
complete in its nature or holistic in its
nature.
So there are a few problems in what they
have come up with and they learn in the
course of time, right?
So the same with AI.
There is a translation.
Lost the chocolate.
Right,
and the translation loss at this point in
time, it can happen in many places,
or I would say at least four important
places: the stakeholder to product
requirements, capturing itself,
there might be loss happening,
requirements to architecture.
design that can be lost happening.
Design to implementation,
implementation to validation.
At every place,
there can be a translation loss which is
happening. And that is where,
why do we actually write documents in the
older times or even today,
why we are writing documents?
To ensure that we go by the contract,
no one has any.
Loss of information is not there when we
are doing the handoff and all of us are
in the same page when we are working in a
product, right?
So that our documents serve as true,
irrespective of the meetings we conduct,
irrespective of the verbal communications
we make, we ensure that we document it.
So without a shared artifact which
preserves the intent, every handoff,
there is an interpretation which comes in.
And whenever there is an interpretation
which is going to come in,
AI can accelerate those steps,
but it cannot.
Reduce the ambiguity.
That was never assaulted, OK?
So let me give you a example.
So you and your clients.
are going in for a meeting.
There is an existing software coming in.
And there is already a software and they
are asking for a new product feature.
So they are asking something and you and
your team had given some validations,
some questions that these features are
already there through this.
This is what we will take it up,
so you have answered. So,
what AI has is a rough meeting transcript,
right? There was no conclusion to it,
so it can generate a PRD from it or
generate a sprint worksheet from it, but..
.
it can, if there is some ambiguity,
it will have to, it cannot resolve that.
So the intent might have been a loss,
it might not have captured it,
it might have left few things,
or it might have done it in a wronger way.
or it might have commented to something
which you didn't plan to do.
So that is where the human has to review
that aspect completely.
So the translation loss is going to be
there if human reviews are not there or
if human control is not there. Right?
Before I go to worry,
we need spec why prompts are not
sufficient.
I will see some chats, I think.
Yeah, GURURAJ mentions model,
make some assumptions and proceed with
them. Yeah, so they make some assumptions.
When you give a very random line,
they make some assumptions and they are,
they do or they take more requirements
from what is what their internal
knowledge they have.
right?
So it might land up in a different intent
for us.
And it also loses the context sometimes
and assumes exactly, right?
So this is the problem we are facing when
we are doing an AI assistant development,
right?
Sometimes the code generated for
greenfield apps.
Pull out updated dependency. Yeah,
that is a very big problem.
The chain supply chain problem.
They make up some libraries which even
that doesn't even exist or which are
obsolete.
Dependency mismatch and security
vulnerability. So that is 1 problem.
problem.
I think in my handout also I have
mentioned it I think a supply chain that
supply chain problem.
There are no libraries or dependencies
like that or it has imported a different
library which is not existing in your
list of accepted libraries.
Right? Yeah. So these are the problems,
of course, yes. So how,
so this spectrum in Development and the
tools which come with that are trying to
structure and give you solutions for some
of these problems,
or I would say it is a best practice. So,
like we had frameworks or boilerplate
codes.
in the previous era, where we,
when I say I want to build a React
application or when I want to build a
Django application,
I just give one line of command and
everything, the boilerplate structure,
some basic instructions,
some optimization steps,
everything that comes in form of a.
framework than it is available to us.
So we can start from directly coding,
right?
So that is what these Kiro spec driven
spec kit and the AI native SDLC by
Anthropic are trying to do.
So they are trying to give us frameworks
so that we can.
Leverage that, right? So now,
before even going into the spec tools.
the frameworks.
Why do you think prompt first workflows
are not sufficient enough?
All of you have understood context.
All of you have understood how prompts
are given, prompt engineering.
So why prompt is not sufficient for a
spec driven development?
Why do we need additional artifacts?
No well-defined guardrails in the prompt.
Yes, limited context, okay. I mean,
all these are additional things,
but basically,
what is the problem if you put everything
only in prompts?
Overload, OK.
Continuity will missing,
non-deterministic outputs are there,
even with spec also, continuity.
I like that Kaushik's answer,
continuity is missing, right? So...
Prompt workflows or prompt first
workflows,
they are good enough for simple tasks,
but if your scope and complexity is
increasing.
Remember requirements.
Constraints, edge cases,
all of this is going to live only in
prompts,
so you can get faster to the output, but..
.
Where is the source of truth?
Right?
So you have to either maintain the
prompts,
or that is going to lead to architectural
drift.
It is going to lead to inconsistent
implementations, reviews, rework, right?
You don't have a source of truth which
you can refer to.
That is where the problem comes.
More token consumption is not a problem.
Even with spec,
you are going to consume more token
because that is also going to go as
context to the LLM, right?
So whether you give it in prompt,
it is going to, if you give it in prompt,
it is going to go as user prompt.
If you are giving it in spec,
it is still going to go to the LLM as
tokens. So token is not.
Conception is a universal problem.
Right,
but prompts are like you are just giving
that it's more.
that memory is going to go to the LLM and
you don't have something which you can
refer back. Or even the AI, not only you,
maybe you can store versions of terms,
but AI cannot refer them back after the
context window expires and new context
window opens, et cetera. Right?
So, we need to create a kind of a.
Memory for the AI,
which can it refer to at all phases
whenever it is having some doubt, right?
So that is where a prompt is not
sufficient. A spec driven workflow,
instead of asking AI to infer.
data or infer the intent from the
scattered prompts, whatever,
for some of which might not be available
to it,
we are having specifying the intent
explicitly in form of a spec which is
available to the AI agent.
And that is what spec driven Development.
is about. It's a spec first approach.
They define guardrails,
they define requirements, constraints,
acceptance, edge cases, upfront.
And AI use it to generate code test and
it also generates supporting artifacts.
which will align with the spec-driven
development.
So the spec becomes the connective tissue
across the entire lifecycle.
It starts with the business intent,
then to architecture,
then to implementation and testing and
validation.
So the AI output stays grounded to the
context which we are talking about.
That is what spec driven development
approaches.
So teams adopt SD spec driven development
because a few things it can.
Reduce the ambiguity and rebook because
the requirements are clear.
Better alignment across even when you
have a spec yourself between different
teams,
you have a better alignment across
product engineering and test through a
shared source of truth.
And faster implement because AI can
generate against a structured set of
information it has.
And more predictable delivery outcomes
because validation is again based on the
original intent, not big.
not based on what AI is assuming, right?
So what happens during the byte coding
phase? You give a set of requirements,
you build a test file,
you build a application,
and you ask the AI to test the right test
cases to test that application.
So it will write test cases from the.
its own understanding or from the code it
has generated.
So there are going to be a lot of
problems in that.
But when you do a spec during development,
the test cases are going to be derived
from the spec.
Or the PRD detail,
but not from the code AI generated,
so that is where you will have a more
reliable validations happening, right? So,
with this, what changes?
So,
we I told you that these are the benefits
it brings in,
but how do we implement this right? So,
that is where some of these tools come in.
So, what these tools offer,
they offer us with the...
Framework.
So Kiro is 1 given by AWS.
It is a AI native IDE which gives you a
structured workflow where you can start
from production vision to implementation.
Then we have the Cloud AI native SDLC
playbook by Anthropic. It replaces the.
stage gate pipelines with continuous
artifacts triggered through Git powered
by the cloud code.
We'll discuss how it works, each of them.
And then we have the Git spec.
So GitHub spec, Git again by Microsoft.
They also give you this.
So what exactly changes? Right?
SDD or spec driven Development.
comes and changes where our team should
invest more efforts.
So more time will go into
Planning and clarifying the intent
upfront,
and less time should go into downstream
work, right? So,
product managers will define scenarios
and constraints.
Architects will shape the planning model.
Engineers will use AI to accelerate
implementation,
and the tests will shift earlier because
acceptance criteria are explicit from the
start. So the result,
what we will have is a workflow centered
on shared intent rather than a
disconnected piece of information.
Okay,
so the idea behind this spec-driven
Development matters or will be useful
only if teams can apply them consistently
in day-to-day engineering work.
And that is where the toolkit or the
frameworks become more important because
that is going to be a standard.
starting point.
It translates the principles of shared
intent explicit thing into a practice,
a practical workflow which can teams can
adopt and scale. Okay,
we will be trying out this hands-on plus
this.
and one of these tools.
I will do it with one and I would leave
it up to you.
We can parallelly try it out.
If you want to explore more tools also,
you can bring in.
I'm not going to restrict that you should
use.
GitHub spec it on the playbook by
Anthropic, etc.
We have to try out many tools because all
of them are in their preliminary phases.
And we have to identify what are the pros
and cons with each of them. Of course,
these tools are also not static.
They are dynamically evolving.
So we have to also look at that aspect as
well. Right? So they will be evolving.
I will tell you, I mean,
though I say it is all easy, important,
there are many problems with using these
tools also. In the last slide,
I will talk about what are the problems
we are facing.
when spec driven developments are there.
Still we are having some issues.
It is not as,
though on paper this looks a smooth
workflow,
practically it is not happening that way.
So a lot of improvements are going in
every space.
So we have to try out and understand
which works.
comparison of these tools or evaluation
of these tools is not that easy because
they work.
Well, for some green field projects,
but when it comes to brown field projects,
we are facing a lot of problems. I mean,
everyone is in the experimental phase and
we have to look at many empirical studies
which tell us how each of them work.
And the tools are also evolving
continuously,
like we tested the internal teams also
keep testing and identifying
the problems and they keep improving it,
right?
So we have to have an understanding of
these tools and we will be using one of
them throughout our life cycle and I
would also,
the assignment also will revolve around
them. So once you finish your exams.
I would start with the assignment.
So the idea of the assignment will go
like this.
Each of you will choose a problem
statement.
So,
the problem statement can be a
considerable simple problem statement,
which you can complete in around to four
or five weeks. OK,
so a simple problem statement, and...
We will go through,
you will choose a toolkit.
And we will start from requirements phase,
design, implementation, testing,
and deployment,
so all the phases will be there in the
problem statement,
but depending on the profile you are
working with, for example,
there might be product managers who are
here, so...
you focus based on your interest,
you can focus more on one face and less
on the other faces,
but all the faces should be there in your
assignment. Okay,
so I pick say I am today I pick a problem
statement to do list. Okay, I want a AI.
Power to-do list to be built.
Now, I'm giving that as an example,
so don't go with to-do lists.
It's like a to-do list is always like a
hello world program we start with. Okay,
think about some very useful thing which
your organization might need or you might
need on your day-to-day life. All right,
so think something innovative.
So, select a problem statement.
I start with the requirements and
elicitation phase.
So if I'm a product manager,
my focus will be more on the initial part,
right? If I am a software engineer,
I can focus many things on look at
optimization base.
in the implementation and testing part,
right? So if you are more into DevOps,
you can focus more on the deployment and
monitoring part. Okay,
so three things you have to start with.
First,
you have to choose the problem statement.
That and leaving it open to you,
every individual,
depending on your day-to-day work and
needs,
you can choose some innovative problems,
David.
Right, second, choose the tool,
either GitHub, SpecGit, Hero, or Claude.
Go with open source if you have Claude
licenses, etc. I mean,
this agentic playbook gives you only
structure.
But it works well with,
it can work with other tools also,
other models also,
but Claude is what they recommend.
So of course, if you have the licensing,
then we can go with Claude also.
So choose what works best for you.
for you, Kiro, GitHub, Spectit, Clone,
and there are many others also.
I saw there is a Tencil or something,
and a few others are coming up.
So you can choose if your organization or
if your workplace is demanding something,
you can choose that also.
So second is to choose the Spectrum.
And 3rd is to choose the area or the
phase where your focus will be very high.
Okay, so in this, if you see GitHub,
we'll spend more time in generating the
PRD in the specify.
So there is a slash specific specify,
which has a few set of skill documents,
which gives basic instructions,
and we have to build our own skills also.
So, um...
The spec kit specify will be one phase.
Clarify and specify both belongs to the
project managers and PRD.
Then the architects,
the design phase is where it starts here.
Then there are tasks.
This is where you break down it.
And implement it,
and then this is the verification phase
to find gaps, and then you implement it.
Okay, so each of these phase we will do,
but which of the phases or which SDLC
life cycle you want to focus more and
what are the say I am choosing a to-do
list today.
OK, and I'm choosing GitHub spec it.
as my tool. Okay, so the third choice,
which phases I want to concentrate,
I can either say I want to focus on the
requirements and elicitation part and I
can say one and two I can do it,
or I can say I will focus more on
only the implementation part,
then I can say I will spend on these two,
four and five, right? So here in GitHub,
we don't have the monitoring,
the maintenance one, whereas in Claude,
we have this.
Anthropic,
I think there is something for after the
build also.
Yeah, it has the deploy maintain also.
I will show you the spectator and this
differences.
OK,
so is that that is how the assignment
will proceed? OK,
that we will start from the 9th contact
section.
So we will have one demo in the class and
you can do it parallel for your chosen
problem statement, the area.
But the focus,
you should define it where you want to
focus because I'm not, I just saw the,
I had collected some responses from all
of you. I saw it as very.
Some of you are product managers,
some of you are software engineers,
developers,
some of them are even DevOps people.
So I would say you focus where you want
so you can improve on that.
But everyone should undergo every phase
to a minimal level.
So because the course is SDLC,
we cannot focus only on one face and
leave out the others.
So every face to the minimal.
So it is like the T-shape, right?
So we will do all the face,
whichever face is your area,
you will go deep into that face. Okay.
This is a heads up for the assignment.
Now coming to the GitHub spec kit.
Right,
so this GitHub spec kit comes up with a
tool. OK, the tool is there.
I can also show you the Visual Studio
Code, which I just installed yesterday.
This helps us to put the Spectrum in
Development SDD into practice.
It is an open source created by Microsoft,
and it provides a structured workflow for
turning requirements into plans,
implementation, and validation steps.
So it stops at validation and doesn't go
to deployment and monitoring.
Later, OK, so each life cycle, right,
is very simple.
The spec kit engineering life cycle,
it starts with constitution that is
defined the intent, defined principles,
standards, and...
guardrails. That's how it starts.
That's the first step.
And the first step which comes is the
specify,
where it captures the requirements,
scenarios, and acceptance criteria.
And next is the clarify.
It resolves ambiguity, dependencies,
and edge cases.
Then, based on what it has,
it goes into the planning,
which translates the intent into
architecture flows and constraints.
And then the plan is broken down into
implementation-ready units.
And then you implement using AI to
generate and redefine codes and
a test, and then you validate that output,
which matches the spec.
Each step reinforces the next,
which makes the flow more predictable and
easier to scale across teams. Okay.
So I will just show you the VS code,
how it looks like.
I have not got into.
The details of what each spec contains.
I mean, every coming up,
but this is how it is.
Okay, so if you go in the GitHub repo,
the spec it is available.
So I have done a specify in it and I've
given a project name and I can see this
kind of a folder which is created.
So basically there are two folders.
One is the GitHub.
Specify and GitHub folder. OK,
these are the two files. OK,
so you have all this created.
Okay, you have the.
I were able to see the VS board, right?
Are you able to see?
Yeah, yes.
Okay.
Yeah, so we have the SMILES.
under GitHub and you can see a skill.
md file under every step. So constitution,
as I said,
is the starting point and then it goes to
specify.
Then it goes to each of the phases.
But this is the starting feed which comes
with it.
And it talks about a few things on memory
also. I will discuss that.
We have to get a little detailed in it.
So, what?
When you have to start with,
there are two main components,
the specify, the dot specify,
and a set of templates and helper scripts.
Okay, specify is a CLI.
It is a helper CLI that bootstraps this
entire project.
So it downloads the official templates
from the GitHub repo for the coding agent
and the platform of your choice,
whatever platform you want to build.
And it sets up the entire Spectrum
Development project in a way that you can
start iterating. So when we,
I don't have the agent yet.
Built in,
but when we are using the chat window,
say I...
Have to chat with it. OK,
here I will use slash specify. OK,
so the exact.
But.
Commands or the skill set green set,
so I can leverage on that. So,
it's a CLI based one,
and then you have the all the others are
the set of templates and helper scripts.
They do the foundation,
they define what a spec should look like,
they give you certain technical plan,
and all of this will be broken further
into.
various other steps which can be taken up.
So these are the two basic things,
the CLI plus the set of templates and the
helper script.
So the big part of the entire GitHub spec
kit is the CLI part.
So it's a Python based tool that can be
used to quickly set up the project for
the STD.
So you use a single command,
which you can see here,
and you can get this entire structure
available to your local report.
And when you run specify,
and when I use the chat mode and I will
go and say slash specify,
that's how I will start writing it.
You will be prompted to select one of the
supported coding agents.
So when you are installing itself,
it asked me. So let me give you.
Okay, so it is installing here.
It will prompt me for certain things,
like what model coding agent I want to
use. Specify is cross agent.
The built-in templates are designed in a
way that it can work with Cloud, Copilot,
many other things.
So we don't have to tweak it.
So these things we don't have to.
tweak it according to the agent,
it can work with any available agent.
And specify will ensure that it downloads
the right version of the agent,
whatever you are selecting.
And the bundled scripts which are there,
they are also available into multiple
formats, these scripts I'm talking about,
right?
So I can select any of see you can see it
shows your coding agent, right?
I can choose any of this.
I select Copilot for now.
And then it an ask.
Choose the script type, right? PowerShell,
Python, etc.
Now this window which I'm showing you,
that is in a PowerShell,
that is in Windows system.
So I will just use PowerShell,
but I can use anything. So when I do this,
you can see it also.
It has created another test project here.
and these two folders are there and it
says go to the project and start using
this.
things, right?
So constitutions is what we start with,
then specify plan, task, implement,
and converge.
And there are a few additional things
also.
So it clearly says run before spec plan
is used,
before spec implement and task for
analyzing. So these are additional steps.
These are mandatory steps which you can
follow and there are additional steps.
And these bundler help scripts,
they are not only available for Windows,
we can have it in Linux, Mac OS as well.
So the POSIG compatible systems plus you
have a Linux WSL also you have one.
So once the bootstraps,
once this command bootstraps the project,
you will have all the folders created.
So this specify folder.
is the one which contains all the SDD
templates, spec technical planning tasks,
along with the scripts for the platform
you choose.
The agent specific folder is what is the.
GitHub folder. OK, so this contains.
The.
from definitions that helps you go
through the SDD process without manually
typing certain process requirements.
And agent-specific forms can also most
commonly be used through the slash
specified plan task, etc.
and the constitution.md file, right?
In GitHub spec kit,
a constitution document is the one which
establishes a set of non-negotiable
principles for your project.
So your organization might have a set of
requirements.
around the testing approaches for web
applications.
Or there might be a convention where
every application that is beginning to
build should always be CLI approach 1st
and then it should go for an interface
based approach, etc.
So there is certain principles you cannot.
Oh.
or they are non-negotiable at all, right?
So all of that is what will be captured
in the constitution document before any
of the SDD iterations starts or it begins.
So this is a powerful tool.
So when you want to,
you are making the framework itself is a
little opinionated,
but you are making it more opinionated,
enforcing certain things through a set of
conventions that guide at every step.
And the helper scripts which are there
are invoked from each individual prompts
to help ensure that it is applied
consistently throughout.
So when specified first bootstraps your
project, it is creating one for you.
This will help the agent manage the
consistency across all.
operations which are being done.
Right,
so not only in implementation at all
operations, right? So,
you start with specify,
so first you write your constituent
document, OK?
The core principles.
Okay.
So this is how these will be
non-negotiable. This will be followed.
without any deviation.
Then you start with the slash specify,
which will start to bootstrap your PRD
document. So this step,
specify step does not include any
architectural decisions.
It excludes all technical decision making,
which is very important. Okay.
So if you're
bringing in your technical architectural
decisions in your specification or PRD,
it's going to restrict it, right?
So you are not defining the tech stack in
the PRD,
but rather focus on the functional
requirements and the motivations behind
it. Then comes the plan.
That is where the technical things will
come and this will generate a plan.
And it will also give you validations
with additional metadata, data contracts.
This plan is where it will be grounded by
the Constitution.
ensuring all decisions fit within the
prescribed guidance we have established.
And then it is broken down into task
using slash task.
into a manageable chunk that AI will do
at one point in time.
Okay, so this is how it will work.
We'll have a complete hands-on at later
part, but just to give you an idea,
this is how it will start with in a
GitHub.
Now there are two more versions I want to
show you. Two more tools similar to this.
That is the key row. Whatever I explained,
I just put it in the slide, okay?
You can refer to it later.
Next is the Kero I want to tell you.
Again,
Kero is a AWS based IDE which was built
for spec driven development.
Now, what Kero offers is on similar lines.
Again, it's a different tool.
It's a AI-powered coding environment.
Kiro focuses on, again,
spec-driven Development approach only.
It has a few set of features I will talk
about. It also starts with spec.
So Kiro approach centers on the workflow.
That is, you start with the requirements,
design, and task. So, Kiro,
3 critical specification files which
serve as the project single source of
truth, right?
Every spec driven development or every
spec will have three main files.
One is the requirements.md file.
captures what needs to be built using
user stories and acceptance criteria.
Indeed.
EARS format that is easy approach to
requirement syntax.
ensuring that everyone understands the
features purpose.
Now you can see there is bug fix MD also
mentioned.
So bug fix dot MD is a starting point if
you are doing a feature change.
And if you are building something from a
scratch, then it is requirements dot.
Next document which gets generated is the
design.md file,
which outlines the technical architecture
into components, data models,
and interfaces,
which will serve as the blueprint for the
implementation, and then comes the task.
md,
which breaks down the work into a
checklist of.
coding task that will build upon each
other,
providing a clear implementation plan.
So this is how it will start. OK.
The main thing with Kiro is the key
features is first it starts with spec.
It converts your prompts or information
into detailed requirements and system
design. So requirements.md, design.md,
and task. And it also has a.
other set of features like agent hook and
autopilot mode.
So agent hook basically it has background
AI agents that can handle tasks like
testing and documentation in the back end.
So it comes with like a very optimized
approach.
reducing the infrastructure requirements,
plus focuses on performance also.
And it also works on autopilot mode where
you don't have to have frequent
interventions or guidance required.
And it is multimodal in nature.
So you can, it is not only.
Text which needs to go the images of
design whiteboard sketches also can be
guided into the development phase,
and it can it has MCP integration wise it
can connect to databases, APIs,
and external tools,
and it works with many.
Popular IDs,
including VS Code compatibility,
so you can work with what.
you have.
So the core idea with Kiro is to go
beyond white coding,
bring up a structured plan,
break that down into small manageable
task,
and agent focuses on the actual goals.
Kiros currently,
I mean there are different versions,
it's mostly paid,
but I think they give you one preview
phase with Claude,
one of the Claude models,
and it works for all operating system and
most programming languages also.
One good advantage of.
hero because they come from AWS
background,
they have a lot of parallel execution.
Right, they, of course,
cloud is basically the fundamental behind
the distributed system and parallel
systems we have, right?
So they build a dependency graph on the
tasks which are created and groups them
into ways. So once the this space tasks.
Is done, it groups,
it builds a dependency graph,
and when you build a dependency graph and
when you run a.
Sort a dependency sort on the graph,
you will know which are which of the
tasks have incoming dependencies,
outgoing dependencies, etc. So,
based on that, it will build a waves. So,
wave one is for all tasks with no
dependencies. These run, we can.
they can run concurrently,
so they will spin off one agent to do
that.
And wave 2 is whose dependencies were
satisfied by wave one.
So they have to run concurrently,
parallelly they can run.
And wave EN continues until all tasks are
complete.
That's how they will divide them into
waves, so you can have parallelly.
execution or concurrent execution of them.
Waves will execute sequentially.
Tasks within the wave can execute
concurrently. So wave one will complete,
then wave 2 will start.
Wave 2 will complete and wave N will
start.
But within this, they can run parallelly.
So it's the best optimized way in which
faster way you can build products.
And more features of Kiro, again,
in two types of spec. One is feature spec,
it starts as a starting point.
New features,
if you're starting with bug fixes,
bug fix spec is your starting point.
And the steering, AWS Kiro has a steering.
agent steering or it is more like a
project specific intelligence and it is
one of the most powerful features of Kiro
I would say.
The ability to guide the Kiro's behavior
for your specific project.
So when you run a setup steering for your
project.
There are three steering files which are
created. Apart from the requirements,
the task MD, the mandatory 3 files,
there are other three steering files
which are created, which is product.md,
tech, structure.md, and tech.md.
You can see the names here.
Right? So what these files will contain,
product will,
dot MD will contain the product vision,
features and target users.
Structure will give the products,
projects,
directory structure and organization.
And tech will give the details about tech
stack and development tools.
And.
These are the mandatory which comes with
the key row.
So what it does is it gives you that
context which is available to the agent
at all times so that they don't deviate.
from the required plan which we are
giving. But additionally,
you can build your own custom steering
agents also.
So I can build a libraries dot MD.
I think Mridul mentioned that we are
having outdated dependencies which can
cause dependency mismatch.
Right? So it becomes a challenge.
So I can build a libraries.md,
which is a custom steering document I
created,
and I say it should not use any libraries
apart from what I have listed in this
file.
So that is a way of creating a custom
guardrail over it.
Right, so we,
so we can build custom steering agents
also,
we can just by writing a spec or an MD
file,
so we can create an agent steering there,
so that's the power of Hero.
OK, and next,
any questions before I move to the
playbook?
Okay, and you move to the paid book,
maybe, and you come back.
So what Playbook offers? Again,
Playbook is by Anthropic.
It was recently released,
I think not even 2 weeks back,
I think August 21st or something,
I mean August last week, two,
three weeks back when it was released.
Again, the intention is same.
We want to go with the.
AI at every face without.
problems which are occurring now and
What is special about agentic this AI
native stSemAIMLstudentsdocs?
They have,
they organize it in terms of plays and
the entire playbook. They have the core,
the plays are the core of the playbook
and they have organized it into multiple
stages which covers the each of the life
cycle.
So, when we start with planning.
Each stage starts by writing to the
version control and it freezes that.
And the next stage begins by reading the
previous handoff.
So, for all the early stages,
you will see that the predominant
artifact is the just MD files.
So the product owner or provides it or
the agent together can build it and read
and act on it. And from the build phase,
you will have the artifact is not just
empty files,
but it is both code and records.
And the chain of comments is also
mentioned everywhere.
So what the agent produced,
who approved it, so that we can.
look at it, revisit it, and ensure,
because human remains accountable for
every decision.
So the human attention shifts along with
the artifacts, but it must be reviewed.
Okay, so an audit trail is created.
Every stage comments and artifacts.
The next stage can read it.
That is how it is built. And together,
the intent, the specification, the plan,
and the review findings are the audit
tree.
So each play will have a starting point.
what changes it has to have been done,
getting started,
what are the how it should go with the
implementation,
what is the governance and how you
measure it, whether it worked or not.
So, each play will be like this,
and these steps are modular,
and you might choose to prioritize
different stages at different times based
on your unique needs,
and each play will name its dependencies
under prerequisites. So,
a state ends by committing an artifact.
which will initiate the next stage.
Okay, so first it starts,
let's say this is how the plays are
interconnected. So intent.md,
capturing intent.md is the planned state,
right? So an accepted intent.
md will trigger the requirements and
design pass.
And approved spec spec dot MD triggers
the plan mode.
a merged PR will trigger the pipeline and
that is how it will go.
So if you look at this,
the plays are listed with each stage.
So the orange ones which you see, right,
they are the ones where you can start at
any point.
Nothing points to it or there are no
prerequisites.
But for other plays like requirements,
design, skills, sub agents, all that,
you have arrows pointing it to it.
So the players have to adopt whatever
comes from the previous step before they
have to start. So first is the plan.
It captures an intent dot empty.
which kicks off the entire software
development process and it can enter to
different routes.
It can go to the build route or it can go
to requirements, etc.
So a person has an idea or a problem to
be solved, right?
They brainstorm and produce a markdown
proto spec.
which is captured in the intent dot MD,
which is both human readable as well as
AI readable.
So if you want to build a new solution,
this works. But what if I want to...
solve the incident which has occurred in
my application. The same thing once.
You write an intent file. Okay,
regardless of whether the intent
originates from an event,
a problem which has occurred, or an agent,
the same steps apply.
So the product owner reviews and corrects
the agent written intent.
Before it is committed.
Okay,
so you start with the proto spec that is
the intent.
So prerequisites for this intent is none.
Right,
and it is there in the intent folder.
It's a one-time task to set this up and
how it how to execute it we can see in
detail later. So it starts with...
describing the problem to plot.
No formal language is required,
it's just brainstorming and it produces
the intent.
Now the most important point is,
I said every play.
We have a...
These 3 things,
plus it will have governance and how you
measure it, right? So,
in terms of governance consideration,
the evidence is committed.
in intent.md,
which will give you the full version
history, timestamp.
It is logged into the git history of the
intent hole.
The project owner or the product owner
should approve or reject the decision,
which will send the intent to stage two,
which is design.
Okay,
and design is recorded as the merge or
the closing review.
So everything we complete audit trail is
maintained here.
And how do you measure it,
whether it worked as intended, right?
So from first conversation to a committed
intent or MD,
You can read from the git history on the
intent home which records all this.
So, that is the leading indicator.
And.
The lagging indicator,
the accept or the reject decision,
is recorded at the merge of the artifact.
So the number of changes made to the
intent that are made after the first spec.
md commit for the same,
those are informations which are recorded
and that gives us a measurement whether
it worked or not.
Knock.
Right, so audit trail serves as the.
solution. Okay,
at this point of time we have we are
still have human review.
It can augment and it can speed up the
way you write the spec,
but it cannot go without a human
reviewing it.
So that is why accept or reject is still
there.
Right.
So to answer Venkata Ajay Babu's question,
how specs are validated,
certain parts of this spec,
when it moves from PRD to the spec,
you can validate through the constitution
in Git spec.
or you can use the steering in Kiro,
or you can verify the audit,
you can bring in the audit skills here
and ensure it.
But certain part of the spec still
requires human review.
Okay, so that is to answer your question.
We cannot, at this point in time,
we are not in a position to completely
leave it after verifying the PRD because
there are still a lot of drift which is
happening.
So now once approved,
the intent is approved here.
In the intent,
it goes to the requirements and design,
the design phase.
It produces a requirements and design
spec. This is guided how it will produce.
This will be guided from the skills
for brand security, compliance, and UX.
So the build skills which you have.
So if you have any organization specific
things,
that will serve as the entry point.
So based on that, it is going to write it.
So.
Front-end work is the clearest example of
this.
Right, and the intent dot MD is accepted.
They give you the mocks.
Clot design, if it is used or other,
I mean, Figma is what is still used,
but here they are saying clot design can
also be used.
and they produce a design spec.
out of this. Okay,
now you can stop at this phase also.
So that is the best thing about this
entire AI native playbook is it is not
necessary that you should go through a
loop. You can start at any phase.
I can even start at this build phase.
leaving out these two phases and start
with only requirements and design and
close it.
Each phase has its prerequisites,
how to execute it,
the governance and how to measure it.
So each of them are independent and
modular in nature.
So in requirements and design,
the product owner starts with the intent
and goes to spec.md. And once spec.
md is committed and its audit trails are
done, then the governance here is.
It looks at the skills which are provided,
and they have to sign off, so...
That the comparison between that is what
will give us the.
measurement of how it works. Of course,
the product owner here signs off the spec
and routes,
the concerns which are there to the
policy owners.
So the leading indicator here will be the
time,
the elapsed time between when intent.
md was committed in Git, Git timestamp,
and the spec.md,
what time stamp it was committed.
The difference between the two compared
with the older requirements,
Plus design cycle,
which we used to do in DAS,
that will be the leading indicator,
the measurement of whether it has
provided,
and the lagging indicator will give us
requirements rework after the build
starts. After the first plan,
what are the changes?
stSemAIMLstudentsdocs.
Brings in all that, OK,
and then we will get into the...
Build a face.
Build.
Again,
it is as a prerequisite intent and
specific spec.md or either only spec.
md if one exists.
and the plot MD file with basic things
will be there.
So the engineer starts with a spec.
md and asks for implementation.
They divide it into a smaller task,
and they come up with a plan.md,
which gives the audit trail,
the PR review plan.
Um...
and all the other details.
So, order of work, risks involved,
proof of work, etc. So, here,
design review happens before any code is
generated. Plan mode enforces this itself,
so the plan and its revisions are logged
off against share of changes that merge.
from the first implementation fast as to
be mentioned here.
Right,
so that's how each phase will proceed.
Now,
you something very attractive here is the
hooks and the Claude MD file,
so it can run an auto mode.
But the engineer approves and once happy
iterated upon,
they don't go for every time they don't
go for edit or checks.
The guardrails will support them in to go
through the entire lifecycle.
So you have an auto mode also.
Ohh.
You can use your legacy systems as the
source of truth as well.
So the cloud.md file gives the context,
conventions, commands, architecture,
details, widget requires,
and the skills are institutional
knowledge.
So how the institution operates,
a version controlling,
how policy changes are implemented.
So those things come under.
skill knowledge. For example,
API design convention or a branding rule
you follow.
So that is what goes into this kill.
md file.
And the cooks are a skill is like an
advisory.
Control,
whereas our hook is a deterministic layer
behind it.
So...
Most claude actions are file edits and
shell commands during implementation.
So the build phase is where hooks can be
built. So build phase hooks,
what they do is they will have some
deterministic checkpoints.
For example,
it can block edits to certain protected
parts or classes or frozen packages.
You don't touch that while changing this.
So certain things it can block.
It can do linting of files.
so that the drift never accumulates.
And it can also keep some credentials out
of the diff.
And so certain deterministic things which
you want to achieve,
which we already have,
can be built in as hooks. So who?
A skill is a advisory.
It has a set of natural language.
You build a skill. So I say, for example,
a secure API,
apply the API security standard whenever
you are modifying an external endpoint or
reviewing the API code or generating an
open API spec.
So you say that whenever you create an
API,
There should be JWT authentication.
There should be input validation.
Every state changing endpoint should emit
an audit event.
So you say these three rules in natural
language and you put it as
stSemAIMLstudentsdocs. Right?
So that is your advisory control.
That is, poop is a deterministic layer.
It says that don't modify this API path.
Deterministically,
it can check who can ask for a human for
approval if it belongs to a stage,
the deployment stage, etc. Or it can also.
..
basically work on based on the
deterministic approach of the hook calls
or whatever the hook is built for also.
So hook will run, it's like a trigger.
We know web hooks, right?
When GitHub and all there are web hooks.
So something similar to it will run on a
trigger and it will check on every action
that matches it.
And it checks for certain things which we
want to.
Do.
Now,
one more thing about this playbook is it
can do parallel sessions and sub-agents,
like Kiro had different agents,
and it can also have steering agents.
A parallel session is another full clock
instance working on a separate task in
its own sub.
work tree, gate work tree.
So a SAURABH agent will run inside a
single session with its own context
window and it will focus only on that one
job which it has been started with.
So this way you can run parallel sessions.
also.
So the engineers puts their work into
tasks which have different files using
the plan,
and then you can work independently.
So that is also possible with plot.
And you have a feedback loop which is
possible.
So when we go to each phases,
we will discuss in detail about these one
thing.
But the main things here in this playbook
is the hooks are as approval gates.
Parallel execution is possible through
subagents.
So these are some highlights in terms of
the playbook. Also,
CICD integration and deployment is also
possible with this playbook.
You will see Kiro and SpecKit stopped in
the previous step, whereas this playbook
It can run within inside a CICD pipeline.
So long running agents can safely run
exposed deployment through MCP
integrations.
And it can also have rollback paths
beyond it.
And maintenance is also there.
Um...
So.
But it's quite new, so we have,
I'm not commenting much on it.
I'm just giving you the information based
on what we have seen from their
documentation.
We have not yet tried the hands-on with
this, so I will give you more information.
what works,
what is not working at a later point in
time.
So now, Martin Fowler,
he is one who we have been talking when
we talked about harness engineering as
well,
and you would have seen him in a lot of
your software architecture related
courses also.
He says the SDD approach can be of three
types. One is spec first,
spec and spec as source.
So spec first approach is what all
development workflows we saw today.
On whatever is the market,
that is what is being followed.
A well thought out spec is first written
and then AI SESHA Development is doing.
A spec is kept even after the task is
complete to continue using it for
evolution and maintenance.
The spec anchored approach and.
The spec has a source approaches.
You don't allow the AI to add anything to
the spec has a source.
You have only the human change it or edit
it and AI goes by that one. Okay,
so these are three approaches he says,
but he has also not.
Um...
Confirm that any of them is a very blurry
area as of now,
because we most of the tools we have,
they follow a spec-first approach only.
Right, after evolution,
after the creation of a new feature,
what happens to the maintenance of the
feature? Again, it is not very clear.
Right,
so the spec is the main source file.
only if it's edited by humans,
and humans never get into coding at all,
then it is a spec as source.
And the spec is kept even after the task
is completed and it evolves along the
feature, then it is spec anchored.
And spec first is what all the and other
things are following.
Right, so...
I have given you the tools,
but as I told you earlier,
the workflow or the process is not as
smooth as we are talking on paper.
In reality,
when these tools are put into practice,
there are many problems which are coming
in, especially brownfield code bases.
We have a lot of brownfield code bases,
which we are not able to touch,
how to fit in.
The SDD approach and these frameworks
into an existing project is a challenge.
We are not seeing good results there.
There are problems which are...
Paste.
Especially when you have a set of
projects and you want to develop one
feature which is AI Augmented or.
Or I had a new AI agent there.
Brownfield, greenfield,
that to a certain extent it works when
you are when you want to develop from
scratch.
But when you want to do something...
from a brownfield check application,
that is where the problem comes.
And also one size,
one workflow to fit all sizes is not
possible.
So when they try to evaluate different
SDD tools, Kiro and Spec Kit,
they are opinionated workflow.
They fit for smaller use cases,
but when the complexity increases,
they are.
having a few challenges, right?
And we have to see whether it will fit
well.
So it has come to a point where we are
reviewing markdown files instead of
reviewing code.
That is what it looks like as of today.
And also a false sense of control
shouldn't come in.
Even with all these files, templates,
prompts, checklists,
there were a few instances where the
agent ultimately did not follow some of
all of the instructions.
Right,
the context window becomes larger with
all these specs.
And because the windows are larger,
AI will,
it's not sure that AI will pick
everything.
Remember the middle problem which AI had,
it might miss something in middle, right?
It might follow something on the 1st and
the last, but something.
It did.
So certain places we are seeing failures.
So we so where that failure is occurring.
Where it is ignoring instructions.
Um...
That is something we have to see,
because we had,
we are having instances of some places it
is missing.
SANKET has a research step somewhere
during planning, and it the...
The agent does a lot of research on the
existing code and what is already there
when you are trying to add a new feature
on top of an existing code.
But when it was doing that,
it ignores the notes that were
descriptions of the existing classes.
It just took them as new specification
and it tried to generate all of them over
again, creating duplicates.
Hey.
So these are some problems which we are
facing.
It has to be an iterative approach,
but we have to have this false sense of
control is something we have to tackle.
And many places you will see functional
and technical specification is not
clearly separated.
PRD should only be on functional and the
spec should be only be on tech, right?
But somewhere you will see a drift
happening and both of them are mixed.
So this will cause us problems and clear
separation of concerns, et cetera, right?
So, where,
what is the size of the problem?
Where does SD sit,
whether it is spec anchored or spec as a
source? All these are.
just uncertain at this point of time as
these tools evolve.
We will see how it goes.
But this is what is the stage today.
We have to see how it evolves.
Some of them you can relate to the other
approaches. So for example,
model-driven development was there,
test-driven development,
behavior-driven development.
So some of these practices you can
directly relate to those things as well.
So if you see spec as a source,
it is more similar to model driven
development where you did the entire
model, you specify the design,
UML diagrams, you specify, etc.
Right.
So all these are attempts to improve the
AI native SDLC and these are different
approaches.
And I would like all of you to understand
that we are not,
this is an evolving field and we might,
we cannot have conclusions.
that this is best or these are the
problems.
And we are not having a silver bullet
face yet.
There are many problems happening.
So with that I will stop here for today.
I have only one more slide which talks
about the AI requirements elicitation.
I will take it up in the next class.
We have to,
so we'll start with the first phase.
That is the requirements phase with the
problem and we will see how they are
being generated.
The PRD is getting generated.
and we'll see some tools with support in
this at this point in time.
Okay, so any questions?
And so, 30 marks mid sem,
just to reiterate,
we expect four or five questions, right?
Yes.
There will be around 4 to 5 questions.
Yes, spec driven Development.
I have given the materials.
I will put the references in the PPT end
as well as this.
So Microsoft has this reference through
GitHub spec,
and the playbook is 1 good reference
there.
I'm just looking at some study where all
these are tested and a comparative study
comes up,
but I think it will take a little time
because it's just,
we have some study on Keto and
the spec driven spec kit alone.
But since the anthropic is very new,
the playbook, we might take some time.
Maybe in the next two, three weeks,
we might have some good study coming up.
So we'll take them as reference.
To do a comparison.
Ma'am,
one quick question: this is about the
traditional AI, the traditional HDLC,
and the AI, right?
The first slide is from the traditional
HDLC.
Yeah.
Your voice is not very clear.
Can you repeat? Oh, shoot. Sorry.
Yeah, yeah, is it here now, man?
Austin, hello.
It is not very clear.
Can you come a little closer to the mic
or?
I will just stop by.
Is it for me? Others,
are you able to hear?
Um, ma'am, is it clear now?
Yes, yes, go ahead.
Okay, so ma'am, I was asking, like,
you know,
in the first slide you have shown that we
have a traditional SDLC,
the different phases,
like starting from your, you know,
recall and design,
and then the the the AI SDLC, right,
where significantly the development time
has been reduced. Now, I mean, you...
You already mentioned that,
but just wanted to clarify,
suppose for testing, right?
It is not about only just development.
Yeah.
In testing also,
there are a lot of automations and
automation testing has been done, right?
So, I mean, if we consider that, I mean,
And.
the length of the test duration in
traditional SDLC versus...
Now in AISDLC,
that should have been also significantly
reduced, like, you know,
compared to what is being done in
development,
especially on the test testing part of it.
Yes,
so now we are seeing that even the QAs
are started generating test cases through
AI, right?
Though we have automation tools,
if we start generating through AI,
Connect.
we will be able to match the speed of the
implementation phase, the build phase.
But from where are you generating the
test cases?
That reliability part is more important.
So in the earlier VYOM coding or the
earlier approaches,
they generated test cases from the code,
which is not a reliable output because it
is also generated by AI.
We might not know whether it follows all
the.
testing, right?
So how a human writes a test without
looking at the code, right, from the PRD.
Got it, got it.
So that is the approach we have to follow,
and that is what they are emphasizing.
Of course,
you can write some unit test or some
basic test from the code,
but when finally comes to what the
feature is achieving,
whether it is achieving all edge cases,
whether it is achieving all things.
Um...
That is where you go to the PRT and
generate those test cases.
And there are still, I mean,
it's an evolving phase.
I can say it is not possible,
but still it is evolving.
Right, yeah, understood.
So, yeah, as Sabina rightly pointed,
we have kind of matured and used very
well or accepted very well in the build
and the implementation phase.
But all other phases are evolving and we
have not matured or we are not completely
able to rely. And there are practices.
different practices and we are not able
to converge on what is the best practice
at this point in time.
That is the problem we are having today.
And this is this has given us a lot of
scope for new avenues, new projects,
and new trials we can go with.
And that is what each of these are trying
out and we are also trying to learn.
Okay.
Yes, ma'am, correct it up.
Okay, yes, Abhinav,
your point is exactly correct.
That building and coding part we are able
to accept and achieve,
but other places we are not yet convulged
on our basic requirements.
Because white coding started two,
three years back,
and now only with agents and other things
we are able to do AI and different life
cycle. That is,
so we will mature very soon or very
shortly, but it will be not in that case.
Okay, sounds good.
All the best for the exams.
We'll have a break of,
we'll not meet for the next two weeks.
We'll meet after the exams. Right? Yeah,
thank you.